gehen sie es auch lieber ruhig an
beklagen die zunehmende hass des alltags
die nicht enden wollende beschleunigung
unserer lebensform dann sollten sie sich
die nächste stunde zeit nehmen für
unseren gast armen aber messi an
denn als überzeugter aktie ration ist
hält er genau diese beschleunigung für
das eigentlich retten der elemente für
den weg in eine bessere freiere
lebensform herzlich willkommen ärgernis
sie sind ein theoretiker derzeit hermann
es ja sie sind auch ein aktueller ration
ist was machen sie persönlich denn
besonders gerne schnell und warum denken
schreiben sprechen ich werde mich
versuchen zu beherrschen
nein also ganz einfach würde ich sagen
alles was man nicht gerne macht wie
steuererklärungen so schnell wie möglich
dann hat man es hinter sich
die sachen immer gerne macht auch so
schnell wie möglich vielleicht dann kann
man mehr davon machen also insofern es
sich nicht so schlimm ist an der
beschleunigung oder an der schnelligkeit
sie sagt uns das schreiben und denken
ist auch etwas was sie sehr gerne
schnell tun sie haben allein in den
letzten sechs jahren sechs bücher
veröffentlicht das heißt sie sind auch
ein denker auf der überholspur und
dieses bedürfnis schnell zu denken das
geht dann auch in die buchproduktion
über ja man kann das sozusagen
kreativität nennen man kann es den
versuchen enden schnell zu reagieren auf
die dinge die die die einen gerade
tangieren müssen ein bestimmtes
verständnis auch von von von denken oder
von philosophie dass dadurch geprägt ist
dass es nicht im elfenbeinturm fernab
der der wirklichkeit stattfindet und in
zyklen von 56 jahren langsam dass man
langsam ein buch produziert und dann
geht es einem verlag und warte man noch
zwei jahre und dann gibt es vielleicht
mal eine englische publikation wo es
dann wirklich internationalen gelesen
wird und man sind zehn jahre vergangen
also in diesen zeit amplituden ist für
mich schwer zu existieren aber wenn ich
irgendwie unruhig und das gefühl dass
gehetzt science das kennen sie gar nicht
wie jeder andere zeitgenosse kenne ich
kenne ich das auch aber das ist
teilweise auch selbst reduziert und ich
sehe einfach dass ich trotzdem viel mehr
viel mehr erreichen kann
dadurch dass ich dass ich besser
vernetzt bin das smartphone das viel
gescholtene hilft es mir im weg vom
flughafen noch drei probleme abzufangen
bevor sie wirklich sozusagen zu einer
lawine werden und und und bestimmte
projekte ganz in die falsche richtung
laufen
insofern ja wie jeder andere beschwere
ich mich vielleicht hin und wieder
darüber dass es jetzt so viel ist hier
und dort aber aber allgemein überwiegend
auch die vorteile weil sie sagten sie
wollen auch schnell mit ihren gedanken
abhalten sie gleich zu büchern
produzieren das widerspricht ja geradezu
dem eigentlichen bild eines philosophen
gesagt ich muss mir drei vier jahre zeit
nehmen dann brauche ich drei vier jahre
bis das buch bestand anders gefragt
besteht nicht auch eine gefahr dass
denkens darin zu nah am puls der zeit
sein zu wollen
also zunächst mal denke ich existieren
wir alle in unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten nicht
es gibt langzeitprojekte an denen man
arbeitet es gibt dinge auf die man
kurzfristig reagieren muss die
philosophie da bin ich sowieso skeptisch
was die philosophie ist also jetzt in
den letzten 2500 jahren
aktion and arlen philosophierens gab es
so viele unterschiedliche arten und
weisen so philosophiert wurde wie
philosophiert wurde wie publiziert wurde
ob überhaupt geschrieben wurde dass das
dass es da sein keine goldene regel gibt
ich denke dass das spannende gerade
heute ist stichwort digitalisierung
stichwort neue medien stichwort blogs
aber auch soziale medien dass wir ganz
neue plattformen sehen nicht nur auf
denen gedacht wurde wir zu einem mittel
szenen gedacht werde ich denke diese
plattformen sind nur etwas neutraler ist
untersagt ich habe diesen diesen
gedanken diese idee den drücke ich jetzt
hier oder dort aus ich denke man muss
diese medien wirklich alles als formate
din format im sinne eines formans nützen
die die die gedanken auch produzieren
überhaupt die man anderswo nicht halt
dass es nicht so dass es nur das buch
gibt dass man über bestimmte jahre
schreibt dass das kenne ich auf und
schätze es auch zugleich gibt es auch
soziale ökonomische zwänge die es einem
einfach nicht ermöglichen zu sagen ich
denke zur ruhe drei jahre über dieses
thema nach also über bestimmte dinge
würde ich gerne drei jahre in ruhe
nachdenken damit das schweizer fernsehen
ein stipendium gibt bin ich gerne dazu
bereit also insolvenzen das auch sehr
abstrakte fragen die auch mit
ökonomischen faktoren teilweise zu tun
haben absolut ich merke schon aber an
allem was sie sagen sie versuchen die
vorteile zu akzentuieren und damit
stehen sie in gewisser weise gegen den
mainstream der linken theorie aber auch
das zeitgenössische philosophierens die
sagen es geht zu schnell wir sind zu
beschleunigt die menschen finden nicht
mehr zur ruhe
können sie denn diese klage überhaupt
verschiedene oder die diagnose für
richtig halten dass da etwas passiert
ist in unserer kultur
also ich kann ich kann nachvollziehen
dass es bestimmte phänomene gibt die man
da will ich sagen fälschlicherweise als
als ein phänomen der das zu schnell sein
so der beschleunigung
herzlicher passiert ja es gibt so etwas
wie ein verschwinden der gegenwart
vielleicht nicht dass das das dann
leicht übersetzt wird ihn ein
die zeit beschleunigt sich ja ich wüsste
nicht wie sich die zeit beschleunigt
also müsste mir jemand erklären was das
für eine zeit ist also ein gummiband
seite mal dünner schneller wird mal
dicker oder ist es eine feder oder also
das sind so vage metaphern oder mit der
falschen felder die die für mich eher
ein hindernis sind so haben die probleme
die die die hinter diesen diesen
erfahrungen oder hinter diesen
wahrnehmung stehen wirklich genauer
genauer zu verstehen
dieses gefühl einer beschleunigung
unserer lebensform das hat sich auch in
einem dokumentarfilm niedergeschlagen
das hat er heißt auf der suche nach der
verlorenen zeit speed und in ihr kommt
eine entschleunigung theoretiker zu wort
hartmut rosa der sehr viel genauer
beklagen kann wovon die rede ist wenn
von beschleunigung die rede ist das
schauen wir uns mal an
herrmann es ja an dieser
das teuflische zirkel der beschleunigung
der hier beschrieben wird von ihm kann
man ja nicht sagen ich weiß nicht was
damit gemeint es irgendwie spüren wir
dass alle in unserem dasein und der
bescheid auf einer gleichung zu beruhen
die etwa sagt es gibt den kapitalismus
der kapitalismus sorgt für technischen
fortschritt und dieser technische
fortschritt sorgt für beschleunigung was
stimmt aus ihrer sicht an dieser
gleichung nicht
ja dieses das ist eine sehr korrekte
beobachtung die ich für die gleichen
sind noch um ein element ergänzen so
sagen das auch eine analyse der moderne
also die moderne ist eine
kapitalistische ist eine auf fortschritt
getrimmte und ist ein auf beschleunigung
wenn man diese gleichung akzeptiert und
auf gewisse weise haben wir die alle
akzeptiert dass ein man könnte sagen die
ideologie oder der blinde fleck unserer
unserer zeit unseres denkens sowohl in
der linken aber auch bei konservativen
traditionalisten wenn man die akzeptiert
dann dann und und gründe zu kritik an
der gegenwart an der kapitalistischen
gegenwart an unserem ökonomischen und
politischen system bleibt denn einfach
nichts anderes übrig als als gegend
gegen beschleunigung zu sein als den
fortschritt generell skeptisch zu
betrachten
das ist eine christin widerstand wird
gleichgesetzt mit beschleunigungs wieder
staat das ist aber eine eine regressive
tendenz denke ich ja man könnte auch
einige elemente aus dieser gleichung
rausnehmen man könnte sich fragen ist
der kapitalismus fortschrittlich löst
die probleme die die die erschafft
müssen wir wirklich auf fortschritt
verzichten ist ist beschleunigung etwas
negatives nur weil sie so lange man noch
fälschlicherweise mit dem kapitalismus
identifiziert wird in dem ein spieler
ist ja ist interessant das ist ganz
unterschiedlich
bereich oder dimensionen an der
beschleunigung erwähnt werden es gibt
natürlich es gibt im biorhythmus es gibt
eine subjektive fahren oder gefühlte
beschleunigung es gibt aber auch eine
soziale beschleunigung die man durchaus
positiv positiv sehen kann
wir leben nicht mehr oder noch nicht
mehr muss man fast sagen in einem
ständestaat in einer demokratischen
förderliste struktur wo man sagt es auch
minarik und jetzt ja die die man
sozusagen gutheißen kann natürlich haben
die immer auch etwas sozusagen stress
haftet für alle beteiligten für
diejenigen die die aufsteigen
aber auch für diejenigen sozusagen von
einem abstieg bedroht sind grundsätzlich
also für mich als auch als politiker
theoretisch gesehen
für das nicht dazu oder darf nicht das
sollte nicht dazu führen beschleunigung
generell zu verdammen
dass man so etwas wie ein kassensystem
hat dass jeder sozusagen im ort bleibt
und weiß es bleibt dabei und es gibt
keinen grund zur unruhe
das heißt nicht dass man sozusagen eine
eine eine ausbeuterische oder oder oder
allgemeinen gestresste gesellschaft
schaffen muss wohl jeder sozusagen von
abstiegsängsten bedrohte ständig ja aber
sie haben natürlich etwas sehr
interessantes auf etwas sehr
interessantes hingewiesen aus meinen
augen denn ich denke das würde ich auch
so ja es gibt den kapitalismus dann gibt
es auf einmal handys dann wird unser
leben schneller dann gibt es die
notwendigkeit vielleicht uns durch
medikamente weiter zu optimieren da
kommt eine neue technische innovation
und so staut sich das und beschleunigt
sich das bis zu einem punkt von dem wir
sagen können das ist vielleicht gar
nicht mehr unser leben so denken viele
menschen so denke ich auch sie würden
also sagen wir sollten vielleicht erst
mal denken vielleicht macht der
kapitalismus gar nicht die
beschleunigung sondern etwas anderes
oder wir könnten beschleunigung als
etwas denken dass auch nicht
kapitalistisch zu nutzen wäre und dann
vielleicht gut für unser leben
es geht um die frage sein welche
tendenzen man in der gegenwart wahrnimmt
und welche davon man man beschleunigt
die technologien die sie ansprechen
man könnte ein bisschen überspitzt sagen
dass die das ist eine ausgrabung werde
technologien gibt oder der techno
wissenschaften die zu bestimmten zwecken
genutzt während der mehrwert produktion
haben die die berühmten ich glaube wird
eineinhalb mal pro tag agenda der
facebook algorithmus diese diese
algorithmen die die die technologie
smartphone das erwähnt haben die könnten
auch anders genutzt werden die könnten
auch dazu führen dass wir in anderen
kooperativen formen arbeiten denken
schreiben und so weiter wozu sie jetzt
in ihnen diesen in diesem in dieser
ökonomie die wir haben wozu den genutzt
werden sind zu einem mehrwert produktion
die einigen wenigen zugute kommt das hat
natürlich ökonomische und dann auch
soziale effekte die die zu ängsten
führen ja das aber sozusagen den
technologien selber zu last zu werfen
ist ist nicht nur falsch sondern es
verstärkt zu sagen diese dynamik aber
einerseits scheint es ja doch so zu sein
dass sie sagen klar der kapitalismus hat
was damit zu tun es gibt diesen satz der
fundieren das für den kapitalismus zeit
ist geld deswegen muss alles schneller
gehen damit alles effizienter wird das
heißt diese klammer die würden sie gar
nicht bestreiten
ja bis zum gewissen gerade ist ja diese
dieser alte garmin franklin formel zeit
sei das geld just in time production
es muss etwas sofort jetzt produziert
werden und dann muss es wahrscheinlich
mit einer drohne bald auch noch schnell
geliefert werden nicht die die die pläne
von amazon das ist das ist in der tat
eine eine tendenz aber ich denke es ist
es ist trügerisch
die die die momentane situation auch die
phänomene die die in dem ein spieler
beschrieben wurden immer nur unter den
auspizien der beschleunigung zu sehen
ich habe den gegenwart spannt schon
schon schon mal werden sie damit
gegenwart und das gefühl dass wir
sozusagen nicht mehr in einer in einer
gegenwart leben in der wir entscheiden
können über die wir verfügen können dass
hier sozusagen als sie uns entgleitet
das ist sozusagen jetzt schon auch so
die ganze philosophie geschichte
hindurch geht dieser debatte gibt dass
die gegenwart überhaupt existiert
überhaupt phänomenal oder ist sie nicht
sozusagen eine nur nur ein fairer
übergang von vergangenheit zukunft aber
vielleicht das essen ist das ein
interessantes stichwort warum haben wir
das gefühl nicht mehr in der gegenwart
zu leben warum haben wir das gefühl
unser unserer unser geschick und zwar so
war sowohl als gesellschaft aber als
auch individuen nicht mehr wirklich im
griff zu haben aber keine traktion zu
haben in der gegenwart zu finden den
reifen der sozusagen im winter sozusagen
auf schnee durchdreht dass es sozusagen
unsere unsere handlungen auch unsere
politischen versuche aktiv zu werden
einfach nicht greifen und das ist
möglicherweise nicht ein problem haben
der beschleunigung sondern eine eine
eines jetzt abstrakt formuliert eines
konsistenz wechsels von vom von zeit für
mich ist die frage wirklich wie wie
verstehen wir zeit und darf ich dann
noch mal einen haken weil dieser kampf
um gegenwärtigkeit und gegenwart der
wird ja von vielen menschen derzeit
gekämpft methodisch zum beispiel durch
solche präsenz techniken wie yoga wie
autogenes training wie ein bewusstes
verhalten von technischen mitteln und
sie gehen aber gegen genau diese
methoden rhetorisch recht aggressiv vor
sie sprechen zum beispiel von einem
nostalgischen entschleunigung fantasien
von folkloristischen lokal ist muss
kitsch sie können auch sagen von der bio
illusion oder der yoga money daher ist
diese form die gegenwart wieder
bewusster wahrzunehmen die halten sie
gar nicht für wirksam in dem versuch
wieder als handelnde zur auf die bühne
zu kommen
also wenn sie dass einige wenige leisten
können also ich komme aus berlin am
wochenende mit dem suv in die uckermark
zu brausen und dort ihre bio kartoffeln
oder selbst geplanten tomaten zu essen
ist so schön und gut
slow food in allen ehren des yoga haben
sie erwähnt ich verstehe dass er als ein
politisches problem also wenn einige
wenige upper class geschöpfe in unseren
westlichen demokratien sich das leisten
können
will ich das sozusagen niemanden nehmen
den stolzen als privileg der gibt
sozusagen absolute die meisten können
sich das nicht leisten und wenn man wenn
man wenn man nicht nur sozusagen sozial
oder als soziologe phänomene beschreibt
oder als psychologe bestimmte selbst
wahrnehmungen von von menschen wahrnimmt
sondern als politikwissenschaftler oder
als philosoph versucht zu verstehen und
auch wenn darüber nachzudenken welche
welche änderungen und welche welche
veränderungen sind sind möglich dann
denke ich muss man auf einer anderen auf
einer anderen ebene ansetzen und da sind
diese persönlichen auch doch sehr
apolitischen wenn nicht sogar
reaktionären entschädigungs fantasien ja
nicht nur nicht nur widersprüchlich wie
vor allem versucht dazu skizzieren
sondern sondern auch kontraproduktiv und
die frage wer so sagen was wäre denn ein
wirklicher politischer und das heißt
auch gesellschaftspolitische ansatz der
der sozusagen einer breiten und auch
globalen auf einer globalen ebene
wirkung zeigt und nicht nur ein paar
wenigen sozusagen zwei wochen
smartphone frei ist hab ich dann noch
mal nachzulegen
ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass
menschen sagen das ist nicht für zwei
wochen sondern nicht ändere mein leben
wirklich ich öffne einen bio bauernhof
im wallis ich sage dass meine kinder
vielleicht nur noch eine stunde am tag
im netz sind
ich versuche eine konsistente lebensform
zumindest in meinem privaten bereich zu
schaffen indem ich diese entschleunigung
entgehen würden sie dann dieser person
auch sagen hör mal du verstehst du das
nicht das ist das privileg dass du hast
im großen und ganzen wird das gar nichts
ändern
ich will es ist nicht die rolle des
philosophen leuten vorzuschreiben wie
lange sie ihre kinder sozusagen mit im
internet sein lassen sollen
das problem ist dass wir alle sozusagen
ständig daten ab sondern dass wir
ständig auch wenn wir nicht online sind
online sinn also die die idee sondern
offline zu gehen sich zu entziehen die
ist die macht wenig sinn also wenn man
sie wenn man sie genau durchdenken
wenn wir einkaufen gehen werden wir
erfasst sie wenn die daten fasst die die
wir produzieren und so weiter
diese idee dass man von einem oft in ein
von einem online seinen offline switchen
kann halte ich für halt die
philosophisch die einzige möglichkeit
die wir haben ist einen einen einen
offensiven und auch optimistischen
umgang mit den neuen technologien zu
haben nur dann können wir sie auch
beeinflussen das ist ja ganz
selbstverständlich wenn man wenn man
wenn man wenn man die technologien
sozusagen den den anderen ob das jetzt
silicon valley ist oder irgendeine große
industrie überlässt ja wenn man
sozusagen einen ganz bewusst einen
technologischen analphabetismus pflegt
dann wird werden die
steuerungsmöglichkeiten natürlich immer
immer geringer und das verstärkt genau
die tendenzen die
gegen die man eigentlich vorgehen möchte
aber es gibt drei ganz interessante
dinge die ich jetzt auch schon
hoffentlich besser verstehen über den
aktionär aktionismus das ist vielleicht
nicht selbst eine theorie sondern mehr
eine zeige handlung dass man auf andere
dinge wert legen sollte und sich nicht
auf diese besteigung theorien nur
verstehen sollte einerseits so will ich
es verstehen aber andererseits habe ich
auch das gefühl das ist eine art
verzweiflungstat es war sie sagen in dem
moment in dem niemand mehr sich diesen
dynamiken entziehen kann
sollten wir sie umarmen was anderes ist
gar nicht möglich da könnte man jetzt
sagen das ist so was wie selbstmord aus
angst vor dem tod das kein opt out gibt
müssen die zu tun als ob wir es mögen
wer da muss ich jetzt natürlich wieder
sprechen ich würde sagen dass er eine
optimistische und progressive haltung
die sagt wir haben eigentlich schon auf
der technologischen ebene auf der
wissenschaftlicher ebene alle
ingredienzien um ein besseres leben zu
führen um eine andere gesellschaft
herzustellen um ohne jetzt als
marxistischer träume rüber kommen zu
wollen um eine post kapitalistischen
post kapitalistische ökonomie oder
gesellschaft zu zu herzustellen
es fehlt die der politische wille und es
fehlt es fehlt die und das
technologische know-how auch ja es gibt
keinen grund warum wir alle länger
arbeiten sollten
warum es später renten geben soll warum
unter den bedingungen der der
automatisierung der roboter die auf uns
zukommen sehe ich eher eine eine politik
und auch eine ideologie die in die
falsche richtung läuft statt dass wir
diese technologie nutzen
[Musik]
schauen wir in die falsche richtung
orientieren unseren modellen der
vergangenheit und und dazu passt
sozusagen dieses ideologische konstrukt
der entschleunigung das nein hat dass
die dass die linke sowie sie verstehen
an verschiedenen dingen leitet die
verstehen die mutter modernen techniken
nicht sie haben keine lust auf die
zukunft und sie denken sie können die
uhr doch irgendwie wieder in einer art
zurückdrehen
in der diese entfremdung effekte die sie
beschreiben einfach nicht mehr vorhanden
sind
ja das sieht man denke ich bei den
großen volksparteien oder was noch vor
ein paar jahren große volksparteien
waren das hat ja auch gründe warum die
immer kleinere nicht volksparteien
werden haben die die die rezepte die die
vorschläge die maßnahmen die die
angekündigt werden orientieren sich
letztlich immer in der vergangenheit ist
das ein bestimmtes ideal aus denen sage
ich mal
frankreich nennt man sieht around
glorious die 30 gloriosen jahre nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg wo ein bestimmtes
sozialdemokratisches modell mit
vollbeschäftigung
mit mit wirtschaftswachstum was politik
einfach funktioniert hat was dabei
völlig ausgeblendet wird ist dass das
sozusagen auf auf wirklich auf den
schutt halten also auf auf der basis
sozusagen einer zerstörung des zweiten
weltkriegs war was dabei ausgeblendet
wird ist dass es wirklich eine eine
historische anomalie war dass dieser
kapitalismus in einem bestimmten bereich
westeuropa nordamerika so funktioniert
auf kosten so zu sagen dass im rest der
der weltbevölkerung dass das ganze nur
möglich war aufgrund eine sehr billigen
sozusagen energiezufuhr stichwort erdöl
also auf lauter sozusagen lauter
konditionen lauter voraussetzungen hatte
die die heute einfach nicht mehr gegeben
sind
ja es ist ja ganz interessant weil wenn
das was sie sagen zutrifft dann ist es
nicht nur donald trump und die afg und
die rechtspopulisten die die zeit in
irgendeiner form zurückdrehen wollen und
sagenweg america great denn sondern die
sozialdemokratie leitet unter derselben
fehlwahrnehmung dass irgendwas in der
vergangenheit besser gewesen sein muss
und nicht in der zukunft besser werden
kann ja das schlimme ist also es gibt
die expliziten ich würde sagen nicht
gegen bares zeitgenossen oder gegenwart
genossen sondern vergangenheit genossen
die alles immer great game machen wollen
also die gibt es nicht nur in amerika
die gibt es in der schweiz gibt es in
österreich die gibt es in deutschland
und so weiter aber auch diese songs vom
selbstverständnis her eigentlich
progressiven kräfte oder oder linken
kräfte die starren gebannt auf diese
gegenwart die sind nicht mehr so zu
sagen unter kontrolle haben und und und
versuchen immer wieder sozusagen alle
vier jahre anzutreten und und ihre alten
tools ihre alten modelle und werkzeuge
zu verkaufen
und irgendwie langsam dämmert es auch
der bevölkerung das dass diese werkzeuge
nicht nur verlogen sehen dass die pläne
nicht nicht nur nicht tragen sondern
dass das einfach nicht mehr funktioniert
und die ängste werden immer größer
angesichts seiner einer wirklichkeit die
sich die sich beschleunigt aber eben
unkontrolliert also dieses gebannt
starren auf technologien und das
beklagen dieser technologien das würde
ja aus ihrer sicht auch den vorwurf
mitbringen dass die politischen kräfte
die heute über unser wohn und wie
entscheiden die technologien die unsere
gesellschaft bedingen überhaupt gar
nicht verstehen und durchdringen eine
form von technologie blindheit der
entscheidenden politischen kräfte mir
kommt manchmal vor es wird noch immer so
demokratie gespielt wie im 19 oder 20
jahrhundert was was was demokratie in
zeiten der digitalisierung bedeutet
welche möglichkeiten der willensbildung
da überhaupt möglich sind oder die
government e government usw wird ja gar
nicht gefragt was was uns in zeiten des
klimawandels nicht nur der politischen
flüchtlinge kriegsflüchtlinge sondern
der immer größeren anzahl an auch
klimaflüchtlingen die die uns
bevorstehen
was das bedeutet politik zu machen was
denn überhaupt politische subjekte sind
der wehr wird teil sozusagen das
politischen forum sind all diese fragen
sich wer höchstens ansatzweise wenn
überhaupt tangiert ich würde da ihrem
ihre einschätzung zu stimmen dass das
die offizielle parteien politik wirklich
an den an den anderen gravierenden
problemen unserer zeit vorbei schrammt
mit ihrem mit mit ihrer
rückwärtsgewandten versprechens politik
reden wir doch mal über das was zu
erreichen wäre sie haben es schon gesagt
es ging darum die technologien so für
ein emanzipatorisches projekt im
weiteren sinne zu nutzen
dazu gehörte wahrscheinlich nämlich an
das grundeinkommen dass die leute
weniger die arbeitszeit verkürzen nicht
verlängern
dass man dafür sorgt dass die
demokratische willensbildung
unmittelbarer und direkter wird sind das
alles dinge von denen sie sagen die
technologie ist da aber das mindset
unser denken ist noch nicht dort ja es
gibt sozusagen er diese diese und das
verbinde ich mit dem stichwort
entschleunigung es gibt er sozusagen den
versuch oder es gibt er diese tendenz
oder diesen reflex ja nicht nicht nicht
unbedingt rational bestimmte negative
effekte zu sehen und die sozusagen auf
die auf die technologien selber zurück
zu führen dann ist das smartphone schuld
dann sind die sozialen medien schuld
weil man sie haben noch nicht schön ist
sondern dass die technikerschule die
technik schuld ja und dann gibt es
sozusagen nur die möglichkeit es so zu
sagen auszuklammern ja man sie zum
beispiel es gibt eine wirtschaftskrise
man sieht dass bestimmte soziale
sicherheiten aus den letzten jahrzehnten
die die wir sozusagen
wiederum in den westlichen europäischen
demokratien in nordamerika gewohnt waren
dass sie langsam wegbrechen die
assoziiert man dann also auf seiten
jetzt der der rechten die assoziiert man
dann mit den flüchtlingen
das sind so einfach so sagen
verbindungen die einfach nicht nicht
richtig sind die einfach nicht stimmig
sind und die auch sozusagen verheerend
sind wenn es darum geht politische
konzepte zu entwickeln
deswegen geht es darum zu sagen diese
lokalen erscheinungen auch die
subjektiven gefühle die man hat in
verbindung zu setzen mit mit der
globalen prozesse und die sind heute
sozusagen wirklich ökonomischer natur
und und und technologischer natur und
wenn wenn wenn wenn das so zu sagen wenn
diese verbindung aus bleibt ja dann gibt
es diese diese immer immer aggressivere
immer nationalstaatlicher agieren wie
die folklore aggressive politik ja es
gab ja mal eine zeit die ist jetzt gar
nicht so lange her da hatte man das
gefühl dass gerade in diesen
industrienationen ein echter politischer
aufdruck aufbruch vonstattengeht 1968
und eines der zentralen kerngedanken
oder kern motive dieses denkens war dass
das private politisch ist dass man durch
eine veränderung des eigenen alltags
verhaltens einen systemwechsel
hervorbringen kann
in allem was sie schreiben lese ich dass
das eine illusion dass und dass man so
naiv nicht sein kann
ich würde jetzt in den 68ern und in viel
zu kritisieren wir haben dem ist es
nicht 50 jahre später das nicht so zu
sagen so einseitig vorwerfen dass sie
dass sie das politische nur im privaten
verordnet haben
da ist schon etwas wahres dran dass man
sagen bei sich selber anfangen sollte
und sozusagen politische probleme zu
sagen auch im zwischenmenschlichen
beginnen stichworte debatte aber
wo ich ihn vielleicht wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe zustimmen würde ist das
ist einfach nicht nicht ausreichend ist
oder nicht zielführend ist sozusagen
diese diese tendenz die es auch gibt in
der linken sozusagen alle sozusagen auf
der privaten ebene alle sozusagen als
als diskurs phänomen zu betrachten und
und und aus dem sozusagen privaten
zwischen menschen hier raus auszublenden
was es sonst noch gibt deswegen mein
plädoyer wirklich im globalen maßstab
diddy diddy phänomen oder die probleme
deren tangieren wirklich im globalen
maßstab zu sehen
stichwort stichwort mit debatte
stichwort flüchtlinge stichworten
beschleunigungen und und und allgemeine
gestresst hat das sind keine subjektiven
die ihn mögen uns einzelnen subjekten
sozusagen alles als ein einzelphänomen
sehr individuell vorkommen aber dafür
gibt es sozusagen allgemeine
gesellschaftliche ökonomische gründe
die damit ganz einfach etwas zu tun
haben wie die wie die
eigentumsverhältnisse aussehen aber
hermann richter kurz einhalten ich finde
es plausibel genug zu sagen das müssen
wir im globalen maßstab sehen es ist nur
für mich für sie und unsere zuseher
nicht so klar was sie auf globaler ebene
eigentlich tun könnten
das ist ja eine gewisse ohnmacht figur
ich sehe die probleme sind so groß sie
sind global
aber was bedeutet das für meine eigenen
handlungsoptionen was würden sie denn
vorschlagen dass ein mensch der die
analyse hat die sie haben und die man
vielleicht teilen kann dann konkret an
dem ort an dem er nun mal ist auch tut
also zunächst mal ist das eine ist es
eine analyse wenn wir darüber nachdenken
wo wir sozusagen ansetzen könnten dann
dann dann wäre das genau so zu sagen
diese zwischenebene zwischen dem dem
lokalen und globalen die frage ist
einfach wo sind heute die die
ansatzpunkte aber was tun
die alte frage der linke nicht wenn sie
von von auf der einen seite den privaten
sprechen nun auf der anderen seite dem
den politischen was 68 jahre
ausgezeichnet hat ist sozusagen dieser
wille auf die straße zu gehen ein
gemeinsames
kunst konzentrieren das erlebnis
sozusagen als als volk als widerstand
ein neues wir zu leben und das ist etwas
was unter denen was was wir jetzt in den
letzten jahren immer wieder gesehen aber
das ist große sozusagen die muss
demonstrationen gibt anti kriegs
bewegungen gegen den golfkrieg sozusagen
relativ wenig effekt haben dh die die
alten sohn widerstands mechanismen
funktionieren auch nicht mehr deswegen
deswegen ist die frage sozusagen wie wie
kann man den fraktionen gewinnen wo sind
sozusagen die hebelwirkungen und ich
denke da ist extrem viel auf der ebene
der der der institutionen zu leisten da
ist extrem viel zu tun
auf der ebene wirklich der der
infrastrukturen und damit meine ich
nicht so sagen die brücken und
autobahnen fahrradwege sondern der der
internet protokolle der algorithmen die
uns wirklich regieren die wirklich
entscheiden wie wir gemeinsam
kommunizieren was wir kommunizieren und
wer davon profitiert weil was wir so
seien hinter all diesen oberflächen
phänomenen wie vermeintliche
beschleunigung so weiter sehen ist eine
eine post kapitalismus der heraufzieht
und eine post demokratische zustände
aber nicht im fröhlichen marxistischen
sinn sondern im naiven 68er
marxistischen sinn sondern sondern
wirklich ein neuer finanzportal is muss
ein neuer
amerikanische technologie theoretiker
hat es einen realismus der cloud genannt
ja das sind sozusagen als plattformen
die also von einigen wenigen regiert
werden oder reguliert werden und unter
rest muss sich sozusagen daran halten
wir haben überhaupt keine
wir wissen nicht nach welchen
algorithmen wir gesteuert werden wir
wissen nicht welche informationen
facebook zu spielt also auf dieser ebene
wäre widerstand sozusagen möglich aber
wie gesagt auch wenn das vielleicht so
unbefriedigend ist weil ich wie jeder
philosoph wie eigentlich jeder andere
auch nicht so lang allheilmittel dass
sie nachfragen des wissens und eine
frage heißt wo wir überhaupt so zu sagen
dass das politische über bahn setzen
also sie haben ja wiederum verschiedenen
finanzportal ist muss sie sagen im
prinzip daten sind so was wie das neue
geld und die karten werden gehortet und
deswegen ist facebook und google sowie
des 21 jahrhunderts ist nicht öl mehr
denke ich sondern sind da zehn tagen
informationen ist der neue free daher
letztlich der über diese daten verfügt
und damit auch uns zu quasi leibeigenen
macht denn es gibt steuerungs wissen
über uns von dem wir nichts wissen
das ist eine formulierung der frage sie
sagten auch und das finde ich sehr
interessant für eine philosophische
sendung ich bin philosoph ich bin ja
erst mal für die analyse zuständig und
nicht so sehr für die auswege eine
analyse betrifft ja vielleicht die krise
der philosophie selbst denn vieles was
sie schreiben sagt wir sind aus unserer
theoriebildung heraus von theorien
geprägt die einerseits nichts von
technik verstehen und wenn sie es tun
technik kritisch betrachten wie
beispielsweise die kritische theorie
oder die frankfurter schule
und sie nennen das sogar einen
transzendentalen miserabel ismus die
idee dass die zukunft eigentlich nur
noch schlechter werden kann als die
gegenwart das heißt kann auch die
philosophie etwas in der befreiung der
zukunft beitragen indem sie die theorien
umstellt es gibt auch eine wissenschafts
feindlichkeit nicht das ist stichwort
frankfurter schule die ich sehr schätze
[Musik]
es gibt auch da sozusagen die idee dass
die wissenschaftlich eine instrumentelle
vernunft und erziehung sind fremde von
unserem eigentlichen menschlichen sein
nicht aber das sind wir auch nahe an der
anderen an den entschädigungs sozusagen
fantasten
ich denke dass die philosophie die
relevant ist in einer zeit und die
philosophie die auch überlebt und die
philosophie die über die akademischen
grenzen hinaus wirkt immer auch das kann
man wirklich historisch sehen selbst
wenn das sozusagen auf eine
dilettantische art und weise gemacht
wurde immer auch in verbindung stand mit
nicht nur den politischen fragen der
zeit sondern mit den wissenschaften der
zeit diese spaltung in auf der einen
seite naturwissenschaft auf der anderen
seite philosophie hat natürlich eine
bestimmte historische notwendigkeit und
hat hat sozusagen ihre gründe in der in
der spezialisierung man kann nicht mehr
heute sozusagen und top level physiker
sein biologie und philosophie
aber es ist auch sozusagen eine gefahr
und ich denke die philosophen oder die
philosophin die mich interessieren und
die die die ich versuche auch zu
betreiben sind immer informiert von vorn
oder versuchen immer in das
philosophische imaginäre quasi
denkformen ergebnisse überlegungen
beobachtungen der wissenschaft zu
integrieren und und dafür auch ein
philosophisches vokabular zu gewinnen
das ist eine der genuinen aufgaben denke
ich der der der philosophie wir reden so
einfach von dem smartphone nicht
ich habe letzte woche weil ich ein paar
tage in moskau
dort unterrichtete sind programm von
einem finger in das heißt die norm aber
nicht was sie dort interessiert und was
ist denn die noch das neue normale was
ist die neue normalität smartphone ist
ein ausdruck der ist so hilflos wie
sliskovic also also wagen ohne pferde ja
oder oder für block stehen sozusagen
digitales geld nicht übersetzen neue
technologien wir besetzen das smartphone
als ein telefon das sozusagen
intelligent ist ist ein großer fehler
das hat ja gar nicht um ein telefon
wissen nicht was das für ein gerät ist
ja sogar finden namen aus der
vergangenheit und dann setzen wir noch
irgendwelche zusätze weil so ganz ist es
ja nicht ein telefon
dann haben wir so hybride ausdrücke dann
etwas am besten post hybrid post
smartphone und so weiter was uns fehlt
sind sozusagen konkrete begriffe die uns
begreifen machen in welche wirklichkeit
wir eigentlich leben also das hingegen
nur den aufgaben der film darf ich ja
gleich ein haken ich meine das ist eine
hübsche idee dass man versucht die zeit
auf den eigenen auf den begriff zu
bringen ja den begriff für die eigene
zeit zu finden
jetzt ist es aber gerade bei hegel so
dass er ja sagt das klappt aber immer
nur zu spät das ist gerade die tragik
der fläche der minerva fliegt können die
begriffe nicht aus der zukunft in die
gegenwart transportiert habe dass er
sozusagen mit mit mit dem französischen
philosophen schilderte löw gedacht so
sagen die philosophie ist die produktion
von von begriffen und begriffe haben
immer auch etwas sozusagen kasten des
begriffe haben immer etwas sozusagen
experimentelles haben immer etwas das
das ausprobieren
wir müssen lernen sondern begriffe
wirklich wie quasi aus der zukunft oder
in die zukunft zu werfen wie eine
flaschenpost und dann sehen sozusagen
welche fraktion gewinnen wir damit was
erreichen sie was machen sie uns sehen
welche sichtbarkeit produzieren sie das
ist sozusagen das sind möglicherweise
neuer aufgaben die wir in dieser
begegnung zwischen sinn neuen zeit
benötigen in einer zeit eben nicht mehr
der biografisch noch gesellschaftlich so
so chronologisch abläuft so aus der
vergangenheit so langsam werden wenn
träger sympathischer fluss in die
zukunft läuft in der man sich sozusagen
in ruhe orientieren kann das heißt meine
these ist wirklich zu sagen die zeit
selber hat sich verändert und dass er
einfach als eine beschleunigung
aufzufassen ist ist ein missverstehen
dabei übersieht man gleich ein phänomen
das sich eigentlich handelt
wir haben hier so eine schöne sanduhr
nicht wahr sie sagen die zeit selber hat
sich verändert sie sagen aber
gleichzeitig auch die zeit läuft genauso
schnell wie sie immer liefern das können
wir hier auch sehen und sie läuft von
der vergangenheit in die zukunft
das dann läuft das so schnell wie vor
2000 jahren liefert genau so schnell
nicht wahr
chris anja die zeit weil sich nicht ist
es denn so dass sie glauben dass die
zeit deswegen schneller läuft weil wir
über zeit gar nicht anders reden können
als in den beschreibungen die die
philosophen über die zeit vorgeben und
wäre es dann so das geht derzeit die
falschen beschreibungen verwenden nur
die philosophen ich bin ja nicht nur
philosophie werde ich auch
literaturwissenschaftler also die
philosophen die tendenz so die wesens
fragen zu stellen und theologischen
fragen was ist die zeit ja und wie
augustinus schon wusste wir glauben dass
immer zu wissen so lange nicht gefragt
werden als literaturwissenschaftler
interessiert mich ja eher so ein
bisschen polemisch zuspitzen weniger die
frage was ist die zeit sondern aus
welcher richtung kommt sie ich habe das
schon angedeutet natürlich ist die zeit
chronologisch sie kommen sondern aus der
vergangenheit lauf durch die gegenwart
in richtung zukunft ganz klar oder auch
nicht
die zeit könnte man auch sagen kommt aus
der zukunft läuft die durch die
gegenwart und bleibt dann immer in der
vergangenheit liegen dass man können wir
uns auch umwelt nun zurückblicken in die
vergangenheit und daraufhin sehen diese
beiden sozusagen paradoxen oder oder
widersprüche in theesen für mich anderen
zu sagen es ist gar nicht mehr klar ob
in einer chronologischen zeit leben es
gibt sehr viele indikatoren oder
anzeichen dafür geben dass das dass wir
nicht in einer schneller werdenden zeit
leben die immer schneller sozusagen in
die zukunft läuft sondern möglicherweise
einer zeit in der das verhältnis von
vergangenheit gegenwart und zukunft
sozusagen immer komplexer wird wir leben
in einer in meiner diktion einer einer
in einer in komplexen gesellschaften die
nicht mehr sozusagen allein aus der
menschlichen gegenwart heraus zu
verstehen sind wir leben in einer zeit
die von von algorithmen computern
automatisierungen gesteuert werden die
teilweise viel schneller funktionieren
viel schneller operieren als als als die
menschliche gegenwart als mensch die
reaktionszeit aber auch die menschliche
denkt zeit das heißt also mich das noch
sagen
in so einem komplexen gesellschaften die
einen entsprechenden sozusagen nicht aus
den menschen gegenwart heraus zu
verstehenden zeit nicht aus dem menschen
gegenwart zu verstehen
derzeit produzieren das heißt wir leben
in einem neuen um es auf den begriff zu
bringen im neuen zeit komplex der der in
dem vergangenheit gegenwart und zukunft
nicht mehr so funktionieren und was wir
bisher zu einen satz den sie da immer
sagen der mir unglaubliche eindrücklich
ist und der wirkliche einer hohen
philosophischen mehrwert hat der heißt
wir können die gegenwart überhaupt nur
aus der zukunft verändern
eine denkweise sie haben es ja wir
müssen die gegenwart aus der zukunft
heraus verändern und es ist ein signum
unserer gegenwart dass wir so denken
müssen und dass das möglich ist und wie
man sich das konkret vorstellen kann
die zukunft zum motor der gegenwarts
veränderung zu machen da haben jetzt ein
kleines beispiel von einem film einem
trailer des films minority report von
steven spielberg da wird nämlich die
gegenwart aus der zukunft heraus
verändern
ein des topfes
auf einer kurzgeschichte von philip
kadic und was hier passiert ist eine
überwachungsgesellschaft wird
installiert aufgrund der fähigkeit von
3,1 an heißen die mörder oder mordtaten
der zukunft vorauszusehen und dann die
menschen zu verhaften
bevor sie es getan haben creative police
das ist etwas was sie ist sehr
interessiert diese logik des präventiven
ja was ist genau da für sie in lucia
biel spielt da sozusagen ist ist ein
officer in diesem programm department
sie sagen dystopische damit haben sie
schon die freunde des films verraten
beginnt ja eigentlich als als einen
typischen als eine kleine utopie einer
gesellschaft in der es keine morde mehr
gibt weil es dieses programm department
gibt dass alle mörder sozusagen aus dem
verkehr zieht bevor sie einen mord
begehen die werden sozusagen für immer
in einer art von ich glaube so
formaldehyd eingelegte also die gibt es
nicht mehr
das ist einerseits könnte man sagen ja
sehr positiv nicht weil es weil es so
lange diese schwerverbrechen nicht mehr
gibt das philosophisch oder moral
philosophische problem ist natürlich
dass menschen die eine tat nicht begehen
für diese tat verurteilt werden ja das
so sagen es gibt sozusagen täter ohne
tat ja man könnte sagen es gibt hier
eine verwechslung sozusagen von vom von
zukünftiger gegenwart und und
gegenwärtiger zukunft prävention ist ist
das phänomen dass bestimmte annahmen
über über die zukunft der rückwirkend
auf die gegenwart einen einfluss haben
das heißt es gibt diese aber es gibt die
annahme jemand wird dieses verbrechen
begehen ja und dann braucht das gar
nicht begehen er ist damit schon ein
mörder geworden wird verhaftet für eine
zukünftige tat die die ja noch nicht nur
noch nicht begangen hat sony begehen
wird wir kennen wir kennen das auch aus
ganz anderen sozusagen bereich mit canon
fremdfonds das ist sozusagen geister
ausdruck das erste mal sagen aufgetreten
in der in der bush administration dass
man kriege führt damit sie nicht aus
planen das sind teilweise sagen
präventivkriege ja dass man sich
sozusagen schützt das das perfide an der
prävention ist um das jetzt zu sein
überspitzt zu formulieren egal wo
amerika in den letzten zehn jahren
gebaut hat hat man nachher sozusagen
diese terroristen gefunden von dem man
vorher behauptet hat dass es sie gegeben
habe
sich selbst erfüllende prophezeiung und
60 wir sehen das phänomen der prävention
auch auf der auf der vielleicht unserem
nächsten das was soziologen eine
primitive persönlichkeiten ändern jeder
von uns einmal den fehler gemacht hat
auf amazon in einem buch zu googeln also
nur zu suchen
geschweige denn zu kaufen bekommt
sozusagen bis an sein lebensende
buchempfehlungen der nächste schritt ist
dass wir sozusagen auch bücher oder
gegenstände wirklich zugeschickt
bekommen und zwar bevor wir überhaupt
wissen möglicherweise dass wir uns für
die interessieren
nun wäre sozusagen der der zwanzigste
jahrhundert gestus quasi zu sagen wir
werden korrumpiert das ist werbung
geschickt
das zurück das perfide an den
algorithmen ist ja aber möglicherweise
dass sie uns besser kennen als wir
selber dass es sich um produkte handelt
die wir wirklich brauchen die wir
wirklich gerne hätten
das heißt möglicherweise wissen
algorithmen etwas über uns bevor wir
selber wissen
das sind alles in der kasse nicht man
könnte auch sagen zum beispiel ja das
ist in der medizin auch so eine
schauspielerin wie angelina jolie war
ist dass sie eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit des brustkrebses hat
und ist deswegen in der lage sich die
brüste abnehmen zu lassen bevor der
krebs ausbricht das war ja auch so ein
fall
da könnte man sagen dass es präventives
operieren ja das ist lukratives
operieren proaktive mediziners das sind
alles phänomene die die im feld der
medizin akzeptieren wir das auf dem feld
der der dessen was ich bei mtv
persönlichkeit genannt habe haben wir
automatisch eine tendenz uns um
sozusagen dagegen zu wehren
das beispiel der der präventiven
polizeiarbeit wie ein neuer report ist
allerdings ein höchst prekär ist und das
ist nicht nur science fiction also in
österreich wird jetzt die frage der
präventivhaft diskutiert es gibt eine in
americana eine weitere debatte darüber
ob algorithmen selber neben nicht
neutral sind einfach nur neutral
technologisch sind sondern sondern
rassistisch nicht wo es besteht ließ
gibt wo polizisten in einem bestimmten
in einem bestimmten bereichen der stadt
gehen dann verstärkt zu sagen schwarze
jugendliche auf drogen kontrollieren die
sind dann sozusagen häufiger im
drogenbesitz als sozusagen in den weizer
werbs
wo nicht soviel kontrolliert und damit
verstärken sozusagen diese diese
präventiven annahmen die wirklichkeit
produzieren eine eine bestimmte
wirklichkeit am deutlichsten hat man das
phänomen vielleicht im finanzwesen also
in mit mit derivaten das sind sozusagen
annahmen über über preise annahmen über
die zukunft die automatisch sozusagen
eine gegenwärtige eine auswirkung auf
die gegenwart haben was ich meine was
ich von meinte mit einem eine
identifizierung von von gegenwärtiger
zukunft und zukünftige gegen war das
heißt gegenwärtige zukunft in dem sinne
was ich jetzt annehmen was morgen
passiert ja das wird nie dasselbe sein
wie das was was morgen in der zukunft
die gegenwart sein wird ja vielleicht
werden die werden in diesem präventions-
phänomenen aber identifiziert und es ist
das genaue beginn unseres gesprächs
anzuknüpfen das sind sozusagen denke ich
viel entscheidende gründe dafür warum
wir das gefühl haben wir können unserer
gegenwart nicht mehr uns bewegen
wir können keine entscheidungen mehr
treffen oder das was wir an handlungen
setzen für dich zu den gewünschten
effekten und das der grund ist er
umsetzt überspitzt zu formulieren
derjenige das dass wir noch immer
sozusagen in richtung zukunft sehen
statt zu begreifen dass wir so eine aus
der zukunft denken müssen dass wir in
vielem sondern schon aus der zukunft
beeinflusst werden und nicht wie wir das
früher war sozusagen vergangenheit darf
ich denn mal nachfragen man könnte ja
auch sagen unsere ganze kultur beruht
auf der idee dass wir die gegenwart aus
der zukunft heraus verstehen zb das
christentum da gibt es ein jüngstes
gericht in der zukunft zum beispiel der
marxismus da gibt es einen idealzustand
auf jedes zuläuft das heißt diese idee
das ist unsere gegenwart durch die
zukunft beeinflusst wird die ist doch
gar nicht neu man kann sagen fast jede
religion die das jenseits ernst nimmt
beruht auf der idee dass die zukunft die
gegenwart beeinflusst wir sind als
menschen sozusagen
gewohnt aus der gegenwart heraus zu
denken
vorstellungen über die zukunft zu haben
um jetzt nicht zu sagen diese chateau
logischen oder oder oder crystal habe
was ich auch visionen der zukunft das
ist auch science fiction wenn diese
wollen da ist ein paradies oder eine
hölle und das soll mein handeln in der
gegenwart beeinflusst ist beeinflusst
das dass das phänomen der prävention ist
diese täter die da aus dem verkehr
gezogen werden
die haben keine chance in die
beeinflusst zu werden denen wird nicht
gesagt du wirst möglicherweise an einen
mord begehen
die sind nicht in der situation wo sie
mit der pistole vor dem opfer sind und
es sich dann anders überlegen
de facto kollabiert sozusagen dieses
programm department an der stelle wo der
officer merkt dass er möglicherweise
einen mord begehen wird das heißt die
freie entscheidung hat ober diesen mord
begeht oder nicht dann kollabiert zu
sagen diese ganze logik dieses dieses
départements das heißt der unterschied
zu dem beispiel die sie genannt haben
und dem was ich mit mit mit prävention
meine ist ist dasjenige dass es hier
eine eine eine der terminierung gibt das
ist sozusagen eine der termin ist ein
deterministische zeit modell ist es
nicht dass jene ich entwerfe mich in die
zukunft ich ja ich habe bestimmt das
ideal in der zukunft und das ermöglicht
es mir das beeinflusst mein
gegenwärtiges handeln ich nehme einen
kredit den muss ich in der zukunft
zurückzahlen kann aber jetzt schon immer
eine schöne wohnung leben das sind
sozusagen
daher hat die gegenwart sondern noch
eine bestimmte offenheit was ich mit dem
beispiel derivaten meine ist da gibt es
keine entscheidung war also der annahme
entfremdete zukunft eine einnahme über
die zukunft entscheidet über die
gegenwart das heißt die die gegenwart
ist nicht mehr offen die gegenwart
gebiet geschlossen
es ist nicht die gegenwart ist nicht
mehr der ort an dem man dem handeln oder
progressives handeln möglich möglich ist
und das ist eben nicht das ist nicht
dasselbe oder etwas anderes als eine der
der beschleunigung ist nicht dass die
gegenwart so schnell vergeht sondern es
ist eher dass die gegenwart gar nicht
existiert oder geschlossen wird als
handlungsspielraum und nicht dass sie zu
kurz ist also
verlust der selbstbestimmung in der
gegenwart durch gewisse kreative logik
durch durch eine bestimmte durch
bestimmte technologien aber wiederum
nicht die technologien an sich selber
das beispiel dass sie mit der medizin
gebracht haben ist ein gutes beispiel
auf dem auf dem feld der medizin haben
wir es gelernt nicht nach unserem
befinden zu entscheiden sondern einfach
nach nach einem bestimmten
wahrscheinlichkeit kalkül die chance
sind so und so hoch selbst wenn sie
diese symptome nicht haben dass sie
diese krankheit bekommen wegschneiden
operieren auf anderen gebieten und auf
auf denen die sozial oder politisch viel
weit weitere zusagen konsequenzen haben
haben wir das und zwar wirklich sowohl
als als subjekt als individuen aber auch
als gesellschaft einfach noch nicht
gelernt mich erinnert das immer an eine
andere wissenschaftliche oder oder
technologische revolution mit dem
buchdruck ich glaube da haben leute 100
jahre lang geglaubt dass der sinn des
buchdrucks ist es die bibel besser zu
verbreiten
die haben sich getäuscht ja weil das
sozusagen gar nicht die konsequenz war
die die die konsequenz sozusagen des
buchdrucks war eine revolutionierung des
politischen systems waren das muss man
auch sozusagen in der gegenwärtigen
situation im erinnern
jahrzehntelange fast jahrhundertelange
bürgerkriege war die konstitution ganz
neuer sozusagen politischer identitäten
den namen nationalstaat wir sind jetzt
in einer ganz ähnlichen desorientierung
dass wir noch gar nicht klar darüber
sind was uns eigentlich wieder fast die
konsequenzen der digitalisierung sind
was wir in beiden fällen haben ist eine
überproduktion an information eine
überproduktion an daten eine über
information an ansehen wie das manche
soziologen auch nennen und mit der
können wir einfach nicht umgehen was
machen wir mit all den daten die wir
über uns haben sie schon vorhanden sind
und diese auch semifinalisten strukturen
die die schon am horizont zu sehen sind
sind ausdruck sozusagen unseres unseres
unvermögens mit diesen neuen
technologien umzugehen
der glaube diese technologien zu
verabschieden ist sozusagen so sinnlos
wie zu glauben man den buchdruck wieder
rückgängig zu machen
man merkt in dem was sie sagen und ich
glaube das ist die philosophie und fern
philosophen sehr wichtig dass ihnen das
etwas bedeutet dass es da einen
persönlichen einsatz gibt und das ist ja
das thema ihres lebens ihres denkens
lebens so weit
darf ich fragen gab es mal eine
erfahrung oder 1 auf märkten oder eine
störung für sie gesagt haben da ist ein
riesenproblem und ich werde versuchen zu
verstehen was das problem ist können sie
diese erfahrung erinnern dieses problem
mit der zeit und dass ich etwas geändert
haben mag damit in ihrem leben
das ist jetzt nicht ein einzelnes
biografisches ereignis ich muss auch wir
reden jetzt selber allgemeinen
allgemeine auch soziale phänomene
dahinter steht ja in meinen texten immer
so auch eine eine abstraktere sozusagen
philosophische auf sprach philosophische
komponente
das heißt für mich sind diese zeit
philosophische fragen immer auch mit
mitträumen raum theoretischen fragen und
mit mit subjekt theoretischen fragen
verbunden
aber um ihre frage zu beantworten da ist
nicht so sagen ein 1 1 ein einzelnes
erlebnis sondern es sind sozusagen
erfahrungen der synchrony erfahrungen
der der fremdheit erfahrungen der der
der nicht jahren lokalisierung an
welchem ort man denn bestimmte
erfahrungen macht oder nicht machen kann
das sind ja
ein koma hat dann aneinander
entsprechenden erfahrungen des dass das
nicht passendes nicht dazu gehören das
einer bestimmten differenz diese
differenz ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ein
wenig biografisch bedingt weil sie aus
einem haushalt in österreich stammen der
ein flüchtlingshaus haushalt ist ihr
vater sind iran aufgewachsen ist
christus armenier und diese differenz zu
der alltäglichkeit die andere ungefragt
sehen die haben sie wahrscheinlich immer
schon gespürt und das ist ja auch etwas
für die philosophie interessant ist dass
man diese distanz und diese entfremdung
erstmal wahrnimmt aber was mich jetzt
und vielleicht viele andere
interessieren würde
so wie sie das jetzt beschreiben stellt
sich die frage ist das was wir hier
reden ist das was sie vielleicht im
alltag tun schon durch diese primitiven
logik so überformt dass wir eigentlich
schon gar nicht mehr frei sind
das heißt sind wir schon eine zone
geraten in denen alles was wir tun nur
noch teil des gestells ist und kein
ausbruch aus diesem gestell mehr
ermöglicht ich finde diese diese
überlegung nicht mehr frei ich tue mir
damit schwer ich glaube wir sitzen alle
in der falle es gibt interessantere
fallen und man sich aus den fallen in
dem man sitzt raus katapultieren
und dann sitzt man den nächsten falle
und muss wieder neue fluchtwege neue
auswege oder kompliziertere oder oder
produktivere suchen so einfach mit mit
der freiheit die sich dann ein für alle
mal verschließt aufgrund von bestimmten
technologischen zusammenhängen würde ich
würde ich das nicht sehen
ein landsmann von in der österreicher
ludwig wittgenstein hat gesagt das
philosophische problem ist immer ich
kenne mich nicht mehr aus ich habe mich
verlaufen und die philosophen müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir den plan finden
was sind denn die drei dinge von denen
sie sagen und philosophen
was müsst ihr jetzt machen um diese
auswege aufzuzeigen und was tut ihr im
moment nicht worin versagt ihre das ist
schwer jetzt da antworte ich jetzt
vielleicht eher er nicht biografisch
oder narzisstisch aber einfach ich kann
nur sagen was ich probiere also ja ich
versuche ja
das ist nicht so einfach dass ich sage
ich ich ich ich hatte mich in die
zukunft und arbeite sondern mich voraus
zukunft die vergangenheit zurück ich
versuche einfach zu verstehen wie in
welche richtung bewegt sich sozusagen
die zeit in welche richtung bewegen sich
bestimmte phänomene
was bedeutet es denn überhaupt ein
philosoph zu sein in einer gesellschaft
in der es angeblich immer weniger zeit
gibt leute immer weniger
ich habe hier meine bücher 300 seiten
sozusagen lesen was bedeutet es sind
überhaupt begriffe zu produzieren seine
zeit zu verstehen und das in eine in
einer gesellschaft einzuschleusen die
eine ganz andere aufmerksamkeit ökonomie
hat stichwort soziale medien
stichwort aber auch sozusagen bestimmte
bilder kultur so eine schnittbild
lastigkeit und und das sind das einfach
experiment auch ein experimentelles oder
oder objektiv ab dieses vorgehen das
heißt nicht dass nicht ein detektiv ist
oder induktives vorgehen sagt vorher
schon weiß also drei jahren fälle
produziert indem es einfach schreibt und
das experiment laufen lässt gleichsam ja
aber das ist so sagen wirklich eine
existenzielle frage weil es auch die
frage betrifft
von welchem ort man denn eigentlich als
als als philosoph spricht das für mich
ist philosophie nicht etwas was ich so
zusagen von vom aus erhobener position
sozusagen als ein meter diskurs
sozusagen über die anderen nicht dein
kind sozusagen er dümmlichen menschen
natur sondern ist eine frage wirklich
ich weiß nicht ich bin mir nicht sicher
in welche an welchem ort an welchen
orten im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
philosophie stattfinden wird
philosophisches denken überhaupt
überleben können wird ich glaube nicht
dass es an den klassischen universitäten
ist das war übrigens auch historisch
nicht immer so und die frage ist oder
was ich spannend finde ist selber daran
mitzuarbeiten an den plattformen an den
denn denn es wirklich den raum zu
schaffen und auch vielleicht die zeit zu
schaffen an denen oder in denen
philosophisches denken
möglich ist aber das unterscheidet mich
sagen jetzt nicht nicht unbedingt von
von künstlern von architekten und von
vielen anderen berufen dass es einen
massiven sozusagen eine massive
verschiebung gibt und so viele
disruptiven technologien
das wird alle lernen müssen sozusagen
was denn was in unserer scheinbar
festgeschriebenen tätigkeiten sind diese
beweglichkeit diese plastizität diese
neugier und auch das bedürfnis dass da
ein problem ist dass wir für alle
erstmal besser in den blick kriegen
wissen dass verkörpern sie als denker
und ich danke ihnen sehr dass sich heute
für uns die zeit genommen haben uns ihre
welt zu erklären welche sagen hermann
das hier und nächste woche ergibt sich
meine kollegin barbara bleisch zusammen
mit dem schweizer bestseller autor rolf
dobelli auf die suche nach dem glück und
fragt wie können wir unser leben
gestalten dass es zu einem gelingenden
leben wird jetzt gleich dreht sich alles
um einen anderen schweizer
bestsellerautor nämlich um martin suter
der in den kommenden tagen seinen
siebzigsten geburtstag feiert nach einem
halbstündigen film porträt spricht der
schriftsteller mit juri steiner über
sein leben und die kraft der literatur
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
ruhigen sonntag
[Musik]